hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel heute geht es ein richtig
leckeres rezept und zwar werde ich eine
schokoladen tat mit himbeeren zu
bereiten und das mache ich jetzt in zwei
schritten und zwar mache ich jetzt
zuerst mal den mürbeteig der muss
nämlich gleich kalt gestellt werden um
später stellen wir ihnen dann eben
zusammen fertig also für den mac braucht
ihr nur ganz wenige zutaten
ich habe hier 80 gramm zucker 160 gramm
butter 240 gramm mehl das rezept kennt
ihr auch dieses mal 123 kuchenteig mein
website ein eigelb eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt und eventuell etwas
milch wobei ich nicht glaube dass ich
gebraucht
aber immer wenn ich sowas sagt frau
wirst du dann doch bewegen kann sein
dass er hilfe braucht zuerst gebe ich
jetzt den zucker in einen mixer in dem
mixa geht's einfach am schnellsten ihr
könnt auch mit den händen verkneten
nur müsste das dann halt ganz schnell
machen weil der muss eben richtig schön
kalt sein und meine zutaten sind auch
alle noch ganz kalt mit sich das einmal
durch
dann gebe ich jetzt noch die restlichen
zutaten mit rein wenn ihr die mutter
übrigens ein paar kleine stücke
schneiden geht wieder besser
manila für den geschmack
und das eigelb und jetzt verrückt ist
erst mal wenn ich merke der teig ist zu
trocken gebe ich eben noch ein bisschen
milch
jetzt ist der teig fertig und jetzt gebe
ich ihnen erst mal in der schüssel rein
damit ich ihnen noch mal einen
kühlschrank geben kann für etwa eine
halbe stunde dann wird er nämlich auch
noch schön fest die zutaten werden
wieder kalt und ich kann ihn dann später
eben einfacher verarbeiten wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr es sogar schon am abend
vorher machen
löst sich das zucker auch noch schön auf
aber so eine halbe stunde reicht
aufbruch
der teig ist jetzt schön abgekühlt und
ich bereits ihr ne tat form vor und zwar
ist es so eine mit so einem hebel bieten
da krieg ich nämlich später die tat
richtig schön wieder raus darin kann man
übrigens auch kitsch und so weiter
machen also süßes und herzhaftes und die
fed ich jetzt einmal mit back rims
playbook stehen lassen und den teig
schon mal aus rollen also die form hat
einen durchmesser von 25 zentimetern und
deswegen muss ich jetzt den teig so ein
bisschen größer ausrollen
so etwa auf 29 cm und das mache ich
jetzt hier auf bislang auf dieses
silikon matte
und dann nehme ich den teig jetzt mit
seinem totenbett
da muss jetzt auch nicht perfekt rund
sein und dann kommt es einfach über
diese form drüber
jetzt muss man nur noch schön rein
und jetzt stehe ich den teig mehrmals
mit einer gabel ein damit er auch beim
backen schön flach bleibt und gebe jetzt
aber nochmal ein kühlschrank so etwa für
eine halbe stunde bis stunde damit er
richtig schön kalt wird und dann wird er
eben gleich gebacken
der teig ist jetzt schön kalt und jetzt
gebe ich ihnen den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze und da
muss als 15 minuten vor button und die
zeit nutze ich jetzt gleich um schon mal
meine creme herzustellen und zeigt mir
jetzt einfach mal hier schnell die
zutaten ich brauch 200 gramm schokolade
da habe ich jetzt so eine edel
bitterschokolade eine schwarze herren
schokolade mit über 70 prozent
kakaoanteil
dann habe ich hier 125 milliliter milch
250 milliliter schlagsahne 50 g zucker 1
eigelb eine prise zimt und später
brauche ich noch etwa 200 in bern ganz
frische und das geht jetzt ziemlich
einfach als ich gebe jetzt hier
erstmalig in einen kleinen topf und koch
die mädels kurz auf und in der zeit
stücke ich jetzt schon mal die
schokolade klein
und sobald die milch aufkochen nehmen
wir sie von der hitze runter und dann
gebe ich direkt die schokolade betreiben
natürlich ohne folie und schaue dass die
schokolade ist auch schön bedeckt es
damit sie sich gut auflösen kann
er kündet auch direkt in zucker mit rein
geben an der sich auch bis auflösen
das lasse ich jetzt hier kurz stehen und
kann hier drüben nämlich schon mal die
sahne mit dem eigelb verrühren
dass eike bruns kurz an dann kommt es
hier nichts ahnen wird schön verrührt
damit eben auch keine klümpchen mit drin
da kommt jetzt noch die prise zimt mit
rein
die müssten natürlich nicht nehmen ich
finde es ziemlich lecker
jetzt kann ich bereits hier wieder die
schoko milch durch röhren damit sich die
schokolade schön auflöst
und jetzt schütte ich diese warme
schokoladenmasse mit zur sahne erst mal
ganz langsam bajramaj mit drin
damit es nicht gerinnt wobei das jetzt
auch nicht mehr so heiß ist dann den
rest und rein
jetzt lasse ich es hier einfach ganz
kurz stehen und bat noch schnell auf den
teig im backofen und dann können wir die
tat gleich fertig stellen
der teig ist jetzt aus dem ofen
rausgekommen und es auch richtig schön
mürbe
ich hätte natürlich auch blind backen
können das heißt und papa streifen
backpapier hinlegen und zum beispiel
soba kerzen oder back wohnen drauf legen
ich habe es nicht gemacht deswegen
drücke ich den teig jetzt einfach ein
bisschen in form weil der geht ja beim
backen so ein bisschen hoch also dass
irgend möglich dass hier besondere
neffen entlang und bei diesen formen ist
übrigens ziemlich gut wenn ihr daran
backpapier darunter ständig beim backen
denn die form hat ja löcher damit eben
diese kruste knuspriger wird und dann
kann es eben aber auch passieren dass
etwas fett austritt und dann einfach in
den backofen ein tropfen
und jetzt fühle ich hier diese leckere
schokoladenmasse 1
die wird auch wirklich durch diese
herren schokolade so richtig schokoladig
weil die er ganz viel kakaoanteil drin
hat deswegen empfehle ich dir euch auf
jeden fall
und damit auch richtig lecker wird gebe
ich jetzt hier noch die himbeeren mit
drauf die kommen jetzt vor dem backen
mit reinen den wänden dann gleich
mitgebracht
und jetzt wird die tat in etwa 25
minuten bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
selbst gebacken und nach dem backen
lasse ich sie erst mal komplett abkühlen
und dann zeige ich euch für ihre
die tat ist jetzt abgekühlt und ich
hatte sich auch zwei stunden im
kühlschrank also nach dem abkühlen
jetzt ist so richtig schön kalt und
jetzt setze ich sie erst mal auf eine
platte um geht jetzt ganz einfach durch
diesen hebel boten
ich setze jetzt einfach mal so drauf und
jetzt bestätigt sie noch mit etwas süßem
schnee muss man nicht machen aber ich
finde das sieht ganz gut aus
vor allem so auf diesen himbeeren und
jetzt schneiden was sie direkt an so
falls ihr euch jetzt wundert wieso hier
so dreckig ist also ich habe gerade das
foto gemacht wenn marios zusammen
deswegen gehe die kleine veranstaltung
auf dem tisch naja wie zeige ich euch
noch den anschnitt
man merkt schon beim anschnitt wie mit
dieser teig richtig
jetzt sieht man hier diesen möbeln
mürbeteig und diese cremige schokoladen
schichtung obendrauf eben diese
fruchtigen himbeeren
ich denke das ist ein super tolles
sommer rezept oder auch winter rezept
könnte auch gern machen aber auf jeden
fall richtig lecker direkt aus dem
kühlschrank richtig cremig mürbe
ich finde da sind ganz viele tolle
komponenten mit drin und falls ich
dieses rezept nach machen wollt dann
geht einfach auf meinem blog auf
jolie.de das stets noch mal ganz genau
und ich freue mich wenn ihr das nach
macht und mit bild auf facebook oder
instagram schickt bis zum nächsten mal
ja
dominik mama video